did you see that video that's going
viral where the girl shows the pregnancy
test and then she's crying like what am
i you saw that ian yeah i just thought
today she's like what am i gonna do huh
just kidding she throws it's like i
already got the appointment well then
she pours a bottle of wine i saw uh phil
labonte tweeted it and he was like it's
an abortion thing yeah
an abortion yeah yeah she was she's
pro-choice oh she already got that right
she's holding the pregnancy test going
like oh no what's gonna happen and then
touch laughing ha ha i am what
conservatives fear and then she drinks
wine or something and i'm like uh i'm
not a conservative i don't fear you but
i am disgusted by you because these
leftists
their their ideology their mentality is
built upon one-upping each other on
social media so they don't realize that
like i grew up in a democrat household
of pro-choice individuals who thought
abortion was disgusting but for
political and liberty reasons and
medical reasons we were pro-choice and
it's a difficult thing and i remember my
dad would always be like you know it's a
really awful thing you should probably
avoid it at all costs but i understand
that it's got to be between the person
and their doctor and i shouldn't be
involved in it and i remember growing up
being like safe legal rare now you've
got one faction that's shout your
abortion pro-abortion it's not
pro-choice it's literally pro abort
michelle wolfe was a netflix screaming
you get an abortion and you get an
abortion and lena dunham says she wish
she had an abortion and i'm like these
videos man these are horrifyingly
disturbing videos for a moderate like
former democrat type personality i go to
my family and they're like this is the
most disgusting thing i've ever seen
we're the pro-choice people not anymore
there was a poll i saw recently
most people agree with safe legal and
rare most people agree with a
restriction on the wide margins yes
margins yeah so who are these fringe
lunatics on social media believing that
is what people like
so phil is correct if there if if there
is a move to the supreme court to
overturn roe v wade it's gonna be
because moderates back off like
you're i'm not on your side you're crazy
it's like i i'm not gonna stand next to
that lady she can go on protest i'm not
doing it no i'll be over there you guys
are nuts
that's the kind of thing that's a really
good example of what's happening there
is a fringe element where they go on
social media and they constantly one-up
each other with the most insane
psychobabble nonsense and regular
democrat voters aren't there
so these people on social media are
dictating what nancy pelosi does to a
certain degree yeah i mean this is how
uh right and this but this is how the
the left is radicalized also
you know i mean now you've got like a
west virginia
you know upper middle class couple with
you know three kids who are social
justice warriors because because they go
on instagram it's the craziest thing
when i go to like west virginia and i
see the flags and i'm like
what are you doing like you don't where
do you live but these people aren't
leaving though i read an article from
the ap
the
the people who are slightly more woke
are leaving west virginia and they're
going to the big cities they're going to
oakland and new york and things like
that so this is this is this is the
physical polarization good that's why i
said i think collapse is inevitable
red states will get red or blue states
will get bluer and then eventually
you're going to have someone in new york
who's like going to run for office
we're going to get to the point where
you have a congress person who's
screaming about how 1619 is fact and
these conspiracy q lunatics believe this
country was founded in 1776. can you
believe it and then you're gonna have
the republican being like because it was
and the guy's gonna plot a cane start
whacking him and you know what that
leads to right right
so when you when you see that the
ideologies are so completely broken
right but we're there already it's just
it hasn't happened yet
it's because i mean all the all the
bricks are in place well no no so
there's still a large portion of older
people who are like sitting there with
their feet up kind of like i don't know
you know i'm i don't understand what's
happening but you look at the younger
generations that are being raised in
this war
millennials gen x there's not so much in
it you know no no i mean this is what i
was just saying this the other day gen x
is like you guys i mean i'm gen x right
you know but then millennials
full scale full-on yeah gen z
it is
substantially more they're they're very
like internet based and so i don't know
where jen alpha will go but i think when
you raise people in this in in this
climate what's going to happen is
a millennial
understands
history of 1776 but then here's 1619 if
their tribe deem it so they say okay
1619. but they still understand
well there are history books but there
are this that or otherwise what happens
when you have these kids jen alpha
growing up where they only know 16 19
from their parents
then they're like
these people are are conspiracy lunatics
who believe in some fringe alternate
history about benjamin franklin like he
has nothing to do with anything he
wasn't he he's not who funded this
country and then what happens when those
two people meet each other over a
conflict
they can't even have a discussion over
the ground they stand on
when you when when the united states
gets into a conflict with another
country we we don't necessarily have
arguments over like
their country versus our country and our
histories it's like resources versus
resources or the future of the countries
hey you need to trade agreement with us
because we want to use this this river
or this straight or whatever well that's
one reason why democracy democracies
don't fight each other right because we
we
we feel like we need to have
conversations about first principles but
what you know we can't have conflicts
about it what happens when you have
the 100 red states 100 blue states and
you go to congress and someone says i
hereby think that all guns should be
banned and the other side says i think
constitutional carry should be universal
those are like so i was reading about
gun control we talked about it a bit
this week in the 80s most states were
may issue concealed carry permits
meaning you probably wouldn't get one
today there's like 20 something plus
states that are constitutional carry
texas just signed it that means if
you're a resident of texas you can just
walk around with a gun you can conceal
it constitutional right to do so that's
a much more extreme version than we than
where we were 40 years ago even for
conservatives and the democrats now are
nominating a guy david chitman who's
like i want to ban all guns that goes
crazy he's nuts he's like any semi-auto
that takes any with a detection magazine
that takes over 22 caliber so it's like
so like every single gun every rifle
sorry okay so what people are saying is
that he's just a plant you know he's
expect an expendable
faint
yeah
in order to get the the next guy in and
the next comes in we'll be alive we're
not going to ban air 15 exactly but we
will nfa them right
so here's what i'm saying the democrats
are at the point where for the past
several years they've been straight up
ban all guns i'm not kidding they they
they've actually advocated for
consistently banning semi-automatic
weapons that's like every single handgun
all of them
that's it that's every almost every
rifle so you have bolt actions lever
actions revolvers but it gets rid of
like 80 90 of guns they just ban them
and then you have the conservatives who
are like constitutional carry and then
you have people like me who end up
following the 2a side because it's
freedom and i'm like everybody should
have a government issued barrett m82
with a box of a thousand i'm kidding by
the way but but i've i've jokingly
talked about semi-jokingly the
department of gun services guaranteeing
the right tone of firearm because it's
in the constitution sure do you want
universal health care well we have a
right to bear arms so we get that first
i digress the point is
the democrats are are to the as extreme
as possible the conservatives are
getting i wouldn't say
extreme but
in a sense i don't want to say extreme
because being like do your thing as the
constitution dictates i wouldn't call
that extreme i would call that
foundational but it is very i think
conservatives are going from yelling
stop
to actually putting their foot down and
say okay we're going to stop that's why
the desantis bill is important yeah
because instead of just you know
bitching and moaning
about big tech censorship it's something
where are the rest of the red states
this is i mean this is this is a problem
this is a this is a huge problem and and
i hope it's an indica i hope it lets
people know about the dire
nature of the situation
everybody do this tell your friends
your state if you're in a red state you
call your politicians and you say please
just do everything desantis is doing
just there you go we're done
uh i will say the tennis bill is good on
social media censorship but i'm i'm told
the abbot one is better so so follow the
texas social media because of ken paxton
who's great yeah so i guess in texas it
actually treats this is what i was told
by alan bakari that it treats the social
networks like common carriers right so
it's like a phone company now florida
doesn't which means it'll be very
difficult to enforce a lot of what they
do hence they're being sued so um but
i'm talking like constitutional carry
and uh social media rights and stuff
like that just desantis
you know do that stuff yeah and and i
mean the other got a call you got to
call and tell them right the other
aspect of this too is is to make sure in
florida at least we've got cities and
municipalities
that are
really excited now i know my you know
the mayor of miami is just excited as as
can be about bringing more people into
miami well he's got to do this in a
responsible way
so as not to bring in you know he wants
to make miami the new hub of big tech
okay that's great you're going to bring
a thousand social justice warriors in
from you know from silicon valley
you know you're not going to win again
if that's what you do i got it i'm i'm
going to start hiring i'm hiring people
and making them all to move to west
virginia
so it's like we're hiring we're we're
hiring and we need to hire like a ton of
people but you got to live in the middle
of nowhere and hey west virginia is
paying people like 12 grand to move
there yep so it's a great opportunity
yeah and there's a bunch of tax
incentives so it's like here you go you
know but i get a lot of people don't
want to necessarily move to west
virginia they want to go to texas sure
and i'm like well you know look texas is
cool and i i get it because west
virginia's not moving fast enough i mean
i have friends who work in dc who are
considering west virginia
as a place where you can commute right
you can absolutely commute and if you
you know maybe you'll you'll go into the
office two days a week three days a week
it's absolutely doable well that's one
of the problems is that parts of west
virginia are turning blue they're almost
blue because dc people are moving it's
it's hilarious so uh the the eastern
part of west virginia is now like 47
democrat
in uh in one particular county because
it's dc dc workers who moved here for
freedom
it's really funny because like you know
like neighborhoods apps and stuff
you can really tell who the city people
are when they're complaining about like
animals and bears and like gunshots
going off and you're like you should not
be living here but but there was a story
that uh ap reported mentioned that
they're actually losing more people uh
the people who are like
lefty pro union anti-gun are like i just
can't stand this it's so weird and
creepy and wrong and they're leaving and
i'm like opportunity guys sure you know
if you want to live in a big city it
smells like sour milk and you can't do
anything
you go ahead and do with my blessing
you want to go in the mountains but that
also speaks to an awareness on their
side i mean you know we're we've been
talking about this conflict and we think
about it a lot and talk about a lot okay
but
the other guys
even if they're not talking about it it
enters their consciousness
i think everybody should move to west
virginia
everybody the world no no no no i'm
talking about like people who are who
are paying attention all of india moves
to you
i mean i think literally you could fit
all of the people in the world into like
houston or something
if they were stacked like shoulder to
shoulder oh okay some ridiculous thing
like that it would like well no no it's
bigger than that but like very little
space no no i'm saying like the people
who are fleeing minneapolis for instance
the people who are fleeing california uh
don't vote for democrats
if you're going to support the local
politics but like people should start
setting up industry i've got places i've
got very little for years i'm telling
people to move to red states you know
florida texas where i mean wherever and
i'm just i you you hear the same things
oh i can't i've got this reason i've got
that reason
okay at some point it's probably going
to get bad enough for you to do it this
is the way i explained it like there's
there's a house and there's a small fire
in the garage and they're like yeah i
know there's a fire there but i think
i'll be fine and you're like at a
certain point the fire is going to
spread to the kitchen and then you're
going to be sitting there and if it
spreads to the door you're trapped
anybody that has a fire in their house
and doesn't take
immediate emergency evasive action is a
[ __ ] and look what's happening with
people who live in san francisco yep if
you're a conservative you live in san
francisco i'm sorry i got it
i lived there for five years and you
left i left there you go there's human
waste all over the ground
when i lived there it was it was clean
it was clean what years were you there
um i was there um
i was there
i guess early 2000s
and uh yeah early 2000s and um
and in the late 90s a little bit too
um but i i didn't want to be surrounded
by crazy people
what part of people pooping
i was on mission i was on mission and
then i was in nob hill before i love
that area i was over there too yeah and
and it was look i mean it was great it
was it was great but the city collapsed
the same way that new york collapsed
which is that the middle class
disappeared and the middle class
overlaps with the creative class too
so when the interesting people leave and
they can no longer afford to live there
i mean
first the families go and then the
people who have no families but don't
make a lot of money and do you know play
music and you know
cultural life things when they can no
longer afford to live in the city you've
got very poor and very rich
and it's boring and the city falls apart
and you know people are saying new york
is going to come back
no
no it may be clean and safe
well in the future you know
but it's not gonna be fun the rats are
desperate and so there's been rat packs
running around the city
so rats used to just eat the refuse it
was easy there was always always waste
once the people disappeared the rats had
to go out and start fighting there's
like a video like a rat fighting a
pigeon and they're like both trying to
eat each other oh my god well look
you've got you know what how many rats
are in new york do you think
millions tens of millions of millions
and there was
and humans were constantly throwing
garbage on the ground for rats to eat
enough for the rats and the pigeons to
sustain a certain level of population
humans all disappeared now all of a
sudden the rats no food pigeons no food
they start fighting each other there's
like a video of someone getting attacked
by a squirrel too like a squirrel's
desperate like biting people yeah and
you get bit by that you gotta go get
your rabies shots sure numerous shots
you want to live there by all means you
do with my blessing i'm gonna go out in
the middle of the woods and you know
i went out i went out today and i
grabbed like 30 or 40 cicadas in like 10
minutes just chuck them into the chicken
nice too
no i'm not gonna eat bugs off the ground
get parasites get the chickens yeah
chickens ate them up gobbled them up
hey it's like i don't got to buy chicken
food this month we got all the cicadas
just it's crazy it's like i go i i walk
along the edge of the property collect
in like 10 minutes like 30 40 cicadas an
hour later it's usually an hour later i
go back out same thing
skaters are all back chickens eat uh
just chicken feet so uh there's a little
egg laying layer is it a protein meal
okay these bugs make grass okay so
an insect can replace you know for for a
chicken uh uh you know cicada is like a
treat oh man oh yeah yeah yeah they go
nuts they love mealworms but they'll
they're omnivores they don't eat
anything they grass they just they they
literally grass
yeah it's funny when you like feed them
grass through the through the wall of
like the coop and there's like freaking
out trying to get it yeah they love it
it's like spaghetti like slurp it up
it's become a thing i never thought i
mean you know whatever i played played
music lived in new york whatever i never
knew that i would have multiple friends
with who owned chickens yeah that was
not a thing that i expected in my life
dude city life is is whack
it's it's i thought it was like the only
way to go for the first half of my life
yeah but communications changed it now
people can work remote now we got
satellite internet now so when when i
was you know wanting to set up a show
i'm like we need good internet so we
want to be in a city
i was it was very difficult to get
internet here it took us like six seven
months i think like a yeah yeah so
we're in the middle of nowhere to get we
we had really bad internet
uh and then in order to get like a
business level internet we had to
and covered probably
really expensive yeah yeah it's probably
like 10 or 20 times the cost of normal
internet or maybe even 30 times the cost
of normal internet i don't know i think
cities get a bad rap
um you know cities get a bad rap these
days especially from from folks who are
you know on the right or folks who have
kind of recently left cities
because um
because they used to be really cool they
used to be a lot different
and it was prior to the social media age
it was when
you know there's something special that
happens with a bunch of
people
you know
in approximately in the same place
music
yeah creativity yeah yeah and but it's
it's it's homogeneous
it it it
made everything boring and the same so
it used to not be yeah i know you know
well i often ask people when was the
last so we have christmas music music
every year
when was the last christmas song written
1998 1994 uh
all i want for christmas is yeah but
prior to that it was what like 1968 and
then 50s and we still listen to the same
songs it's culture homogenized and then
stagnated thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you